♪♪
>>> So we're learning some new
details about the objects that
were shot down by U.S. Fighter
jets over the weekend.
This is according to a Pentagon
memo obtained by CNN.
The omts shot down over Alaska
was metallic and the size of a
small car.
The object shot down over Canada
was a small, metallic balloon
that crossed near sensitive
sights in the U.S. Before it was
shot down and the object shot
down over lake Huron on Sunday
slowly descended into the water
after impact.
Now, the objects were flying at
altitudes between 20 to 40,000
feet.
Military decided to shoot them
down because at those altitudes
they could pose a threat to
civilian aircraft, which would
be really, really serious.
Joining us now, white house
national security counsel
coordinator for strategic
communication and that's John
Kirby.
John Kirby, thank you for
joining us this morning.
I appreciate it.
>> You bet.
Happy to be here.
>> Since we last officially
heard from you, any briefing or
any update that we should know?
>> Nothing I can say
operationally, don.
We still have not located the
debris from the three objects
shot down over the weekend.
Although, there are intensive
recovery operations under way to
try to find, locate that.
Once it's been located to try to
recover that.
But nothing to report.
Now on the spy balloon that was
shot down a week or so ago,
divers were able to get into the
water over the course of the
weekend and were able to recover
a significant amount of debris,
including some of the structure
and some of the electronics.
All that has been shipped off
now with our FBI partners.
We're going to try to analyze
that, see what we can learn.
>> It almost seems like this is
something novel and now the
United States and I know it is
not.
Should it take the U.S. Military
this long to recover these
objects especially if the U.S.
Is the one that shot them down,
John?
>> You know, when you do
something like this, don, you
want to do it over areas where
you're not going to hurt people
on the ground which means it
will be remote areas as best you
can.
Then just getting to those
remote areas can be difficult,
don.
Particularly if you throw in not
only the latitude at which these
things are located, at least the
first two but the weather
conditions right now.
It's February and up near the
arctic, the weather conditions
are not permissive for search
and recovery operation.
>> This is fascinating to folks
just watching at home.
Everyone is wondering, what's
going on?
Why so many.
Is this new.
If you're looking for more, I'm
paraphrasing here, you're likely
to find them.
Is that what you believe?
Is that what -- is that what our
intelligence folks believe?
>> We think in part, don, that
this could explain why you've
seen so many incidents in a
short period of time just over
the last few days.
We adjusted the norad staff
adjusted the parameters for the
radar systems.
The sensitivities to look for
things that were low -- I'm
sorry, slow, high, and small.
Small radar cross section in the
wake of the Chinese spy balloon.
So when you're doing that, when
you adjust your sensitivities on
the radar, you're likely to see
more of those kinds of contact.
We think that's in part why
there have been these most
recent incidents.
>> CNN also learned the first
missile launched at the object
over lake Huron did not hit the
target.
Do you know where that missile
is?
Does it concern you if missiles
are missing targets that over
American people, over, you know,
the United States?
>> I can't confirm the reporting
that a missile was fired and
missed.
I would add a couple of thoughts
here.
One again, these were very small
radar cross section targets.
And so, it's not inconceivable
to me as a former military man
to believe that one might have
missed just because of the size
of the target.
And there are safety mechanisms
in place that pilots use.
I don't think the American
people or the Canadian people
need to be worried about the
possibility that one of those
missed.
>> But that is our reporting
that it did not hit its target
and this is happening over
American air space.
If the standard operating
procedure going forward is to
shoot these objects down to keep
civilian aircraft safe in the
sky, can you guarantee Americans
on the ground that Americans on
the ground will also stay safe
as well, John?
>> Yes, I can, don.
>> As simple as that, even
though you said you don't know
if it was -- where that missile
is and you can't confirm, but
that is your reporting?
>> I can't confirm your
reporting.
There are safety protocols with
all these kinds of engagements.
The whole purpose of these
missions were to keep Americans
safe.
That's what was behind the
president's decision from the
very, very beginning.
Make sure we were keeping the
skies safe for civilian air
traffic.
These three objects were at
altitudes that could potentially
pose a risk to commercial air
traffic.
And also, they pose a potential
surveillance risk to sensitive
sites on the ground.
It's all about safety and
security of American people.